now to texas where an 18 year old
student accused of a shooting at a high
school there is in custody this morning
four people were hurt in the incident
however the suspect's family says he was
only trying to protect himself from
bullies maria virial is at the scene in
arlington that is just outside of dallas
texas maria good morning to you
hey good morning tony right now school
is canceled here at timber view although
there are still a lot of cars lingering
in the parking lot left behind by
students and staff during the chaos this
all started when a fight broke out on
the second floor of the school you see
behind me when one of the students
allegedly pulled a gun he started to
shoot and everything went on lockdown
when reports came in about an active
shooter inside timber view high school
heavily armed police converged on the
school searching the campus and
surrounding areas for signs of shooting
suspect timothy simkins frantic parents
gathered as close to the school as
possible desperate for any information
on their children we're scared we're
scared we just want to go in and get our
kids as the chaos unfolded outside
inside the school students were sharing
this video police believe it shows the
brawl that provoked the shooting this is
not a random act of violence this is a
student we believe right now preliminary
that it was a student that got into a
fight and drew a weapon dale topham a
teacher at the school and a father told
us he and his students barricaded the
door with these desks during the
shooting my thought was
if my daughter
were in a situation like this
i would want someone
to keep her safe it's an all too
familiar scene playing out in schools
across the country federal data shows
school shootings have more than tripled
from 2000 to 2019.
you never know
when it's going to be your last day
so i'm very thankful to have my daughter
with me relieved parents gathered at a
nearby school where some 1700 students
were being bused wednesday morning after
the shooting luckily i finally got a
text and said mommy i'm okay
a few after hours after the shooting
sims simpkins turned himself in with his
attorney at the police station he is now
facing three charges of aggravated
assault with a deadly weapon and he
could face prison time as for the
victims right now we do know one is
still in critical condition but they are
all expected to be okay gail
well that's good news to hear that
everybody's going to survive so
upsetting for the parents not knowing
that's an awful feeling thank you maria